let's do a little bit of probability
with playing cards and for the sake of
this video we're going to assume that
our deck has no jokers in it you could
do the same problems with the joker
you'll just get slightly different
numbers so with that out of the way
let's first just think about
how many cards we have in a standard
playing deck so you have four suits so
you have four suits
and the suits are the spades the
diamonds the clubs and the hearts you
have four suits and then in each of
those suits you have 13 different types
of cards or sometimes it's called the
rank so each
each suit
has
types
of cards types of cards you have the ace
then you have the two the three the four
the five the six seven eight nine ten
and then you have the jack the king and
the queen and that is thirteen cards so
you can have
for each suit you can have any of these
for any of these you can have any of the
suits so you could have a jack of
diamonds a jack of clubs a jack of
spades or a jack of hearts so if you
just multiply these two things you could
take a deck of playing cards and
actually count them take out the jokers
and count them but if you just multiply
this you have four suits each of those
suits have 13 types so you're going to
have 4 times 13 cards or you're going to
have 52 cards in a standard playing deck
another way you could have said you're
like look there's 13 of these ranks or
types and each of those come in four
different suits 13 times four once again
you would have gotten 52 cards now with
that out of the way let's think about
the probabilities of different events so
let's say i shuffle that deck i shuffle
it really really well and then i
randomly pick a card from that deck and
i want to think about what is the
probability that i pick
what is the probability that i pick a
jack
well how many equally likely events are
there well i could pick any one of those
52 cards so there's 52 possibilities for
when i pick that card and how many of
those 52 possibilities are jacks
well you have the jack of spades the
jack of diamonds the jack of cl of clubs
and the jack of hearts there's four
jacks there's four jacks in that deck
so it is four over 52 these are both
divisible by four four divided by four
is one 52 divided by four is 13.
now let's think about
now let's think about the probability
so i'll you know we're going to start
over i'm going to put that jack back in
i'm going to reshuffle the deck so once
again i still have 52 cards so what's
the probability that i get a hearts
what's the probability that i just
randomly pick a card from a shuffle deck
and it is a heart its suit is a heart
well once again there's 52 possible
cards i could pick from 52 possible
equally likely events that we're dealing
with and how many of those have our
hearts
well
essentially 13 of them are hearts for
each of those suit you have 13 types so
there are 13 hearts in that deck there
are 13 diamonds in that deck there are
13 spades in that deck there are 13
clubs in that deck so the 13 of the 52
would result in hearts and but and both
of these are divisible by 13 this is the
same thing as one fourth one in four
times i will pick it out or i have a one
and four probability of getting a hearts
when i go to that when i randomly pick a
card from that shuffle deck now let's do
something that's a little bit more
interesting or maybe it's a little
obvious
what's the probability that i pick
something that is a jack i'll just write
j it's a jack and
and it is a hearts
it is a jack and it is a heart
well if you're reasonably familiar with
cards you'll know that there's actually
only one card that is both a jack and a
heart it is literally the jack of hearts
so we're saying what is the probability
that we pick the exact card the jack of
hearts
well there's only one one event one card
that that meets these that meets this
criteria right over here and there's 52
possible cards so there's a 1 in 52
chance that i pick the jack of hearts
something that is both a jack and it's a
heart now let's do something a little
bit more interesting
what is the probability you might want
to pause this and think about this a
little bit before i give you the answer
what is the probability of so i once
again i have a deck of 52 cards i
shuffle it randomly pick a card from
that deck what is the probability that
that card that i pick from that deck is
a jack
oar
or a heart so it could be the jack of
hearts or it could be the jack of
diamonds or it could be the jack of
spades or it could be the queen of
hearts or it could be the two of hearts
so what is the probability of this and
this is a little bit more of an
interesting thing because it's we know
we know first of all that there are 52
possibilities there are 52 possibilities
but how many of those possibilities meet
the criteria
meet these conditions that it is a jack
or a heart and to understand that i'll
draw a venn diagram it sounds kind of
fancy but nothing fancy here so imagine
that this rectangle i'm drawing here
represents all of the outcomes so if you
want you can imagine it has an area of
52. so this is 52
52 possible outcomes now how many of
those outcomes result in a jack so we
already learned this one out of 13 of
those outcomes result result in a jack
so i could draw a little circle here
where that area and i'm approximating
that represents the probability of a
jack so it should be roughly 1 13 or 4
50 seconds of this area right over here
so i'll just draw it like this
so this right over here is the
probability of a jack
the probability
the probability of the jack it is four
it is there's four possible cards out of
the 52 so that is four fifty seconds or
one out of or one out of 13.
1 13. now what's the probability of
getting a heart well i'll draw another
little circle here that represents that
13 out of 52. 13 out of these 52 cards
represent a heart and actually one of
them represents both a heart and a jack
so let me so i'm actually going to
overlap them and hopefully this will
make sense in a second
so there's actually
13 cards that are a heart
so this is the number of hearts number
of
number of hearts and actually let me
write this top thing that way as well
that makes it a little bit clearer
that we're actually looking at let me
clear that
so the number
number of
jacks number
of jacks
and of course this overlap right here is
the number of jacks and hearts the
number of items out of this 52 that are
both a jack and a heart it is in both
sets here it is in this green circle and
it is in this orange circle so this
right over here let me do that in yellow
since i did that problem in yellow
this right over here is the number of
jacks and hearts so let me draw a little
arrow there it's getting a little
cluttered maybe i should have drawn a
little bit bigger number
of
jacks and
and hearts
number of jacks and hearts and that's an
overlap over there so what is the
probability of getting a jack or a heart
so if you think about it the problem the
probability is going to be the number of
events that meet this these conditions
over the total number of events we
already know the total number of events
are 52 but how many meet these
conditions so it's going to be the
number it's going to be you could say
well look the green circle right there
says the number that gives us the jack
and the orange circle tells us that the
number that gives us a heart so you
might want to say well why don't we add
up the or why don't we add up the green
and the orange but if you did that you
would be double counting because if you
add it up if you just did four if you
did four
plus 13 what are we saying
we're saying that there are four we're
saying that there are four jacks and
we're saying that there are we are
saying that there are 13 hearts but in
both of these we're in both when we do
it this way in both cases we are
counting the jack of hearts we're
putting the jack of hearts here and
we're putting the jack of hearts here so
we're counting the jack of hearts twice
even though there's only one card there
so you would have to subtract out where
they're common you would have to
subtract out
the the the item that is both a jack and
a heart so you would subtract out a one
another way to think about it is you
really want to figure out the total area
here
you want to figure out the total area
you want to figure out this total area
and let me zoom in and i'll generalize
it a little bit so if you have one
circle like that and then you have
another overlapping circle like that and
you wanted to figure out the total area
of both of the circles combined you
would look at the area of this circle
you would you would look at the area of
this circle and then you could add it to
the area of this circle
but when you do that you'll see that
when you add the two areas you're
counting this area twice so in order to
only count that area once you have to
subtract that area from the sum
so if this area if this is if this area
has a this area is b and the
intersection where they overlap is c
is c
their the combined area is going to be a
plus b
minus where they overlap minus c so
that's the same thing over here we're
counting all the jacks and that includes
the jack of hearts we're counting all
the hearts and that includes the jack of
hearts so we counted the jack of hearts
twice so we have to subtract one out of
that so it's going to be 4 plus 13 minus
1 or this is going to be this is going
to be 16
50 seconds and both of these things are
divisible both of these things are
divisible by
4 so this is going to be the same thing
as if you divide 16 by 4 you get 4 52
divided by 4 is 13. so this is there's a
4 13 chance that you get a jack or a
hearts